so it's great to see you here for the
premiere of white bird a blizzard
tell me what attracted you to make this
movie great to you thanks for being here
and talking to us about the movie
appreciate it what attracted me I mean
really Gregg Araki I've been a fan has
forever I always kind of want to hope
that I would fit into his world
you know the worlds that he creates and
almost got to work with him on the last
movie and all my friends did so I was
super jealous and luckily he did he
agreed that we should work together for
this one yeah and what did your friends
tell me about the experience of working
with the kaboom they were working on was
yeah yeah you know all those guys um
what are they what did they tell me I
mean they don't have to tell me honestly
I just said that but I was lying cuz
what do you have would have to say about
Grady rocky yeah you just want to work
with them you know yeah now what was the
actual experience like did it live up to
what you thought would be in your head
and and how is it working this charleen
as well yeah it's it's it every
filmmaker is different you know so you
know I don't necessarily know what to
expect you come to a meeting you meet
with them you talk you sort of think you
have an idea about it which was crazy
about Greg is is it's like he already
knows movies gonna make you know and
that's that's why they're so specific I
think so come to the set there's not a
whole lot of like surprising he'd cast
the movie correctly everybody comes to
work he sets the movie up the way he
wants to so he knows exactly what he
wants you know that's it's the
difference sometimes you work with
people were a little loose and sometimes
it doesn't come together in their vision
whereas Greg's very taut and tight and
Sharleen it was great you know uh we had
a before she went off and did her big
old spider-man and all the crazy stuff
she's doing but it was just awesome you
know we every day that I was on set we
got to there's a lot of downtime so we
got to hang out and just talk to each
other and try to figure it out in the
relationship and um yeah it was a joy
she's I've had a lot of great co-stars
women right I've had made amazing girls
that I've worked with and she's
definitely the top as we all know she's
fantastic isn't she definitely now we
know you've got lots of small stuff
coming up we're looking forward to as
well as white bird you got um return to
sender haven't you tell us a little bit
about that your your fellow countrywoman
hi president Pike yeah that that's a
real dark picture and I haven't seen
anything from it I have no idea but it
was it was cool again another amazing
woman and just to create this insane
relationship that we share in the movie
was really special I learned a lot from
her you know she's an amazing actress so
I don't know I don't know I haven't
heard a word about coming out it's not I
don't know how to media and this queen
of coffee as well is that right yeah
yeah that that was a movie that uh my
friend and I made we wrote in like a
week and we shot it like over two weeks
like a week later so it was just an
experiment it ended up sort of on the
internet and stuff I don't know if it
will come out I think it's a really cool
art film one of my best friends Mardon a
McGinnis directed you we see more behind
the camera as well as in front do you
think it's giving you a taste for that
yeah yeah absolutely you know I don't
think I'm a great screenplay writer I do
really enjoy writing I want it I mean I
wish it was a writer you know they I'm
probably a better writer than I'm an
actor I would hope to think that you're
a good actor but I'm not but I'm not I'm
not a good right anyways but um yeah I
think so I'm it's crazy got to make a
living and you got to keep one thing
going it's hard to so if I get my hands
dirty working on a project like that and
then you have to go act and focus you
all your energy on that it's it's just a
weird it's hard to get this going but I
have an idea I have an idea
yeah can't tell us any more
yeah it's sort of the house - it's just
like I'm America and Fame about sort of
like American Idol what it's doing to a
country and looking up to people and how
we respect the artists that you and I
might have respected as kids and how it
thinks being instant how it might affect
your psyche and your family and and and
your desires and wants yeah awesome
can't wait to see how you get some time
to work on it yeah if you can work with
anybody going forward directors and
actors who would you have on your wish
list um right now I'm doing a pilot with
this guy mark Rosner who's the creator
of the show and honestly it's like I
never thought I would meet such a
creative sort of equal and somebody that
I trusted implicitly as much as I do him
so I mean that's next I go back to New
York to shoot this pilot so hopefully
goes well but he's amazing so it's a
little bit about what it'll involve
what's it's about well you know I made a
couple pilots one one became a show one
didn't so you never know you know it's
like it's like if it doesn't I guess it
doesn't get picked up you never see it
it's cut Blanco and it's like about a
sort of a half Puerto Rican American New
Yorker raised in Washington Heights who
gets into sort of a drug war gets busted
ass he just has to decide if they're
gonna rat for the government or or spend
time in jail etc etc it's sort of like a
Whitey Bulger type story and there's a
documentary here I think so I want to
see it yeah I heard it was great
cannot wait for all of those things
Italy to speak to tonight and enjoy
their family oh thank you so much
you